I have to tell you about how Donald
Trump and his kids and his businesses
are being enriched by Trump's own
campaign so far Republican nominee
Donald Trump has paid nearly eight
million dollars of the campaign
contributions that presumably some
hardworking people donated to him to his
own companies and to the company's of
his kids according to filings with the
Federal Elections Commission the
campaign now sort of been transitioning
to the general election and these
payments are starting to ramp up in May
over a million dollars or nearly twenty
percent of campaign spending that month
was redirected either to Trump's
businesses or to Trump's kids businesses
and paul s ryan not to be confused with
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan uh who
directs the UH he's the deputy executive
director of the campaign Legal Center
said that some of the actions that Trump
is taking our legal but that it's so
unprecedented that a candidate has so
many businesses that are being
subcontracted by the campaign sort of a
patchwork of legality or lack thereof
that has not been figured out one of the
things Trump is done and this is just
fascinating it's legal for a candidate
to rent space from themselves in other
words if you own a building and you want
your campaign run out of that building
the campaign can pay the owner of the
building which could be you the
candidate rent but what Trump has done
in Trump Tower is more than tripled the
cost of rent there now that he is using
rather than his own money remember Trump
used to be self-funding the campaign now
that it's actually donors that are
funding Trump's campaign all of a sudden
rent at Trump Tower for Trump's campaign
offices has jumped from 48 grand a month
to just under a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars a month can you imagine
if you're one of these middle class or
lower middle class Americans is I want
trom cuz he's gonna win believe me he's
gonna be terrific for us and he's gonna
bring back jobs that don't exist that
he's here
outsourced to Mexico and China in the
first place you fall for that nonsense
so you say I'm gonna give my hard-earned
50 bucks to Donald Trump and then he's
artificially increasing the price that
the campaign pays his company for rent
in his own building I would be furious
if I was one of those people donating to
trump if they even hear about this which
they probably won't they'll rationalize
it in some way yeah because Trump is a
hero and Trump can do no wrong and
that's how they see him uh and it we
theorize that this was the whole reason
he's got into this in the first place
yeah it wasn't because he thought he
could win it was because it would be
good for him uh in terms of his
popularity in his image and his brand
Trump's campaign buys their bottled
water from Trump ice Trump's bottled
water company Trump's campaign spent a
bunch of money at a vineyard that
happens to be run by his son Eric trump
the money is going to all sorts of uh
Trump kids the UH you have manufacturers
of trumps make America great again hats
going to uh uh a board member in Eric
Trump's charity I mean it's all
completely incestuous the other day
trump's daughter Ivanka wore a dress
from her fashion line tweeted about
where people could buy it after she wore
it at the National Republican National
Convention and then all the sudden
Nordstrom's and Macy's were sold out
this is the business Jason of running
for president and if if we can we can
criticize Trump for many things he knows
how to turn running for president into a
business doesn't pretty much I mean so
my new theory is going to be that this
wall the reason he's building this wall
is to raise the price of his actual suit
so he can actually sell those for more
money to yeah uh everything is
self-serving isn't it Louis it really is
yeah and if he were really the hero that
working-class Americans think he is but
he would his campaign money would be
going into their businesses right and
into these small businesses and it's
just it's really disgusting what happens
before the election is a sign of what
would happen after the campaign has been
total chaos since the beginning why
would that change if Trump becomes
president and the entire campaign has
been a self self serving cell
enriching uh project why would that
change after the campaign ends I've
talked about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David